[Music]
all right i got some tour dates coming
up february 25th and 26th i'll be in
kansas city missouri at the comedy club
of kansas city then march 10th and
through uh march 12th i'll be in
springfield missouri at the blue room
comedy club and then just announce april
8th and april 9th i'll be in salt lake
city at wise guys comedy club enjoy this
episode with little brows damn
my guest today let's go
little browns in the new spot in the new
spot yes
you you sat down with me three times
yeah there's our third one this is the
third one this is the third one
it's managed uh twice yeah yeah yeah
yeah we back now you're here i'm here
this is amazing right
you know what i was uh
someone was asking me about it um they
were like you know what made you want to
do the switch what made you want to do
this instead of its manage and i was
like you know when i was doing this
manage i was kind of just like existing
you know and it kind of was just there
right you know it wasn't like anything
that unique to it you know like i felt
like every conversation i had with when
i started having guests i thought was
really good conversations but it kind of
just was just like
it's there it's you're six you're now
you're living yeah now ooh now this is
you um
it feels like you this chappelle's world
right doesn't feel like me it does right
[ __ ] it how are you doing browsing good
bro i'm good yeah how are you i'm good
man yeah yeah dude it's it's it's uh
it's always dope to watch everything
that you do
uh and i've finally gotten like some
insight to see uh you do the things that
you do oh yeah even in the studio in the
studio yeah been in a studio and you're
good bro your vocals blew me away ah no
god don't let him lie he you can hit
some crazy screamo vocals yeah
that shit's crazy i've never done it
but like i don't know
was that your first time recording
yourself like hearing yourself recorded
and stuff yeah in a studio yep wow oh no
no no sorry i made a love album for a
girl back in uh high school
is this the one you burnt on a cd yeah
is that still out there anywhere yeah uh
one of my buddies still has it oh my god
he has it he has it all on his uh
drive oh yeah he had he like on his uh
yeah hard drive yeah it was
it was so funny it was a love album yeah
but i titled it legacy of brutality
that's amazing how many songs did you
put on it
it was so stupid
what grade we talking gosh i had to be
like 16 something like that
yeah yeah when i recorded it and how
many tracks it was seven tracks we did
wow i did uh like damn you dropped it i
did some ep yeah i did like four
acoustic songs
four i did like four acoustic songs
and then
a rap song and then my buddy did two on
his own i was like yo get on this you
know just put two of his tracks on there
went off yeah we gotta fill this out a
little bit
yeah because i was like i don't have i
was like i want to give an album i need
an outro i need an outro like we need
everything yeah it was so funny because
my buddy
whose house i recorded at this was at
his parents house obviously right right
and uh he had a whole setup and we only
used a mac
you know this was 2003 2004 yeah and so
like it had the garage band and we like
the mic we used was through the like you
had to you know get close to the
computer yeah and the funniest thing
about it was that whenever we were
recording he had a red light outside his
room so his mom
knew tell me
that's straight high school dude it was
so dope man we're recording mom yeah
chappelle's doing his vocals right now
when you first got in the studio was it
pretty nerve-wracking because wait when
you did the um
when you did the when you were doing the
king of the steam freestyles you had
never been to this oh wait no no you had
i mean i started similar like garage
band at my house like me and my brother
would record with a little tiny speaker
and we would have actually before
garageband we would have a little
microphone beside the speaker
and we would record like with the
speaker playing the audio and over the
audio in the mic you know what i'm
saying damn it it was tricky yeah it was
like a whole system we had that's the
first way i ever recorded and then but
like okay so there's that yeah and then
there's like actually going in to
a studio yeah
there's a producer there's these like is
that pretty nerve-wracking that was
nerve-wracking yeah i was yeah because
like with your brother it's like yeah
we're goofy right right yeah that's how
we start no judgment here because we're
like both yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm going
you know i've always been trying to i
just love recording myself i think a lot
of musicians and stuff will say that
like that's one of the reasons we do it
is to like hear our stuff back yeah so
i've been trying to do it since i was
little so it started like that but the
first time i went to a studio i was
super nervous i booked like three hours
because i was like i need to come in
there and like like make sure there's
like everything set up and i finished
all my stuff in like literally 45
minutes
and i'm just like sitting there and he's
like what else do you want to do and i'm
like i mean i have more i have more i
could do anything did you do more no i
did it
i was like wait this one's not ready
yeah i was just i was that out here in
l.a or back home in uh ohio that was out
here
yeah yeah i was out here
how did you link up with this
uh i just found him online i was looking
for engineers and like people that could
produce and stuff yeah and i think just
through a mutual friend through
instagram i like booked his studio space
out and came with my stuff prepared and
i had like two hours remaining that like
we didn't even do anything he showed me
youtube videos and i was like this one's
sick yeah you sat there every two hours
two hours just doing that just doing
that yeah but but like
you know it is pretty dope cause like
but yeah how do you i don't know like
when i was in the studio recording with
you mm-hmm
like i did a track on an upcoming yeah
one that you're working on for uh thick
boy
thick man himself uh brendan shaw bishop
so and uh he asked me to come
do some vocals on a
talk about it on a
a hardcore song and uh
i've never like done
like i can sing punk but it's not like
screaming it's like you just yell
and like yelling doesn't like really
take anything you're just like it's
still my voice like i don't have to like
adjust it but just besides just make it
higher yeah you put the notes out but
this one's like
this you're like you're like
right right right and it's crazy you did
great bro i'm just going to brag i'm
going to brag on you a little bit my the
producer i work with he's really good
and he makes people do takes like a
thousand times in a row uh-huh and
chappelle did his in literally i think
one take like one take lacey yeah was it
one type
he did it in one take and i think that's
what they called me we were like he did
he did it in one take he killed it and
then i'm sitting there looking at the
producer all sitting there and he's just
like yeah we're good i'm like i know
that was insane to me i was like because
i mean obviously i don't know i've never
like done like vocals like that you know
like in in
i don't know you just said
uh you just played me the track and i
was like okay i felt the track and then
i was like here it goes you know
it's [ __ ] insane i can't wait for
people to hear that one and that we also
got chris garza from suicide silence yep
you know shout out to guitar shout out
to that [ __ ] guy he shreds he [ __ ]
insane
he's insane how insane is that dude he
just like he he brought like
all the equipment yeah he brought it
full studio to the street
reed's studio yeah shout out to bass
guys
that's
b-a-s-god g-a-w-d yep uh shout out to
reed shout out to reed uh
[ __ ] has like a little room
that's like it's just basically a closet
yeah chris garza brought all the [ __ ] he
brought the whole studio we had wires
going out stuff to the kitchen we were
basically using this whole house to
really i mean yeah cause i i
had left after i did my
oh it got crazy when you left bro we
literally utilized the whole house we
had like amps going into the bathroom
like microphones going into the kitchen
it was [ __ ] it was dope we got some
good stuff though i can't wait for you
to hear the final mix i know i can't i
can't wait to hear this [ __ ] final
mixie yeah yeah so you so you're working
on the thick boy stuff and also you're
doing your individual stuff right which
is really dope too yeah you just dropped
something
yeah i got a song uh that came out
what's today when's this come out
tomorrow comes out tomorrow okay so it's
out now thank you
yeah it came out yesterday yeah yeah and
it's called internet browser just a
basically a wrap like straight bars type
of track
and uh yeah i've been working on a lot
of music so usually once i am in the
studio a lot working on all these
melodies and like songs and stuff i just
want to put a song out that's like
straight yeah you know
yeah
i've obviously you know seen you since
your journey has has started
you know and but like how are you
feeling about it now like like where
you're at and where you're
yeah where you're headed you know yeah i
mean [ __ ] started moving so fast after
king and the sting i really just ran
with it and got out of my own way and i
was like i'm just gonna roll with this
so now to see like
just all the love i've got and
you know people actually like the music
so it's just yeah motivated me to like
keep putting stuff out
um but yeah it's just been i know yeah
yeah because you you keep that strong
grind in general like you're not someone
i look at that goes like
you know
like oh this guy he's just he's just you
know
he's just doing it you you know what you
do like you actually do it yeah yeah you
know yeah and i was really impressed
what you did uh on my boy boo like kev's
uh freestyle
i don't know is it freestyle fridays he
does
basically yeah yeah or something like
that i i i don't know exactly what it
was but i think he had sent me the
no he had text me right and and i didn't
see
what you did yeah but he was just like
yo oh that's cool you boy low brows
he went off that's dope and i was like
what did he do you know and he was like
oh i had him on he came in and uh spit
some bars
and that was [ __ ] insane and [ __ ]
mark harley wraps it all the [ __ ]
time
he wraps it all the [ __ ] time yeah
but it's but it's dope to see like to
actually like that you actually
are leaning into it and actually [ __ ]
going for it man thanks man you know
like i mean i don't i just like
surrounded myself with those kind of
people me too you're one of those people
man you're super motivating and
and all yeah shout out to boo lake kev
for having me on that that was like a
cool experience because he hit me up two
days before right and he's like i want
you to come on and spit some bars yeah
so i basically wrote that 48 hours
before i went on there like i need new
fresh stuff like i just want to snap
and but i thought i could only have one
take because i was like this is like
freestyle fridays yeah yeah yeah it's
like 106 in park time yeah one take to
nail this
so i literally like i re i recorded it
on my laptop and i listened to it for 48
hours straight and my headphones and
like drove myself nuts bro like yeah i
can barely listen to that song anymore
but see that's that's what i love in a
person a person that like that's go that
got this opportunity yeah and you know
got asked to do it two days before right
and it's like what the [ __ ]
and then to [ __ ] be like let me
[ __ ] drill this right let me drill
this let me work my [ __ ] ass off yeah
to make this happen and make it good and
that's what that's the beauty of it it's
like
obviously the result in what you did and
like the bars you spit is dope but the
foundation of it the root of it of like
[ __ ] kicking ass on it at it or
whatever like doing what you can to
do good
is like that's the dope part to me dude
you brought it 106 apart did you ever
watch it there's around this time
there's this dude named blind fury of
course
dude amazing [ __ ] first of all he's
an i think he's under [ __ ] raiden
yeah he's insane he's underrated type in
blind fury
106 in park freestyle dude goes off
oh
[Music]
damn he has so
brand new challenger in the building go
ahead and introduce yourself what's
happening
let's go
baby
so he's blind by the way you're gonna
know that casey enhanced blind berry
[Music]
let me save us all a little bit of time
i'm blind so now you gotta think about
your rhymes put all the corny lines in
them laying more jokes man how they let
this clown escape from oakland i don't
even know he's even broken
[Music]
whole crew is on up corner your little
squad there will be ready for my groom
so tell them you coming home like video
bruh type in blindfolded versus ace ko
or something like i don't know uh
k9
k-9 k-9
yeah he's amazing dude everyone there's
this one this one got me the most
because
this guy goes hard about him talking
talking [ __ ] about him being blind and
[ __ ] all right right
but we want the guys
fast forward a little bit
yeah
[Music]
so just listen to this first news rep
and then watch how blind fury comes back
god that was so hype dude this is so
[ __ ] high
we gotta bring that back yeah yeah let's
bring that what makes your world
freestyle friday
no we
[Music]
turkey sandwich was a good
punch
[Music]
[Applause]
only way i lose if i'm judged by a blind
jewelry okay now this guy's freestyling
he's blind
casey he's blind
he can't see be clear that wasn't like
his eyes
[Music]
i know
anyways everyone he's battling is
bobbing along with i know everyone
everyone everyone he battles vibes with
it they're like they can't help it well
[ __ ] you know what i'm like he's [ __ ]
really but that i think that dude is so
[ __ ] underrated i used to watch uh i
remember
this period of time when he was on
uh
those those freestyle fridays from 106
and park yeah like i loved watching
those me too you know what i mean people
don't think i watch bet because they see
all the posters and [ __ ] i'm like they
thought they were more just in tv yeah i
was more empties eat a dick
i watch b-e-t
you hear me
and i'm talking to you meatball cause
you said it
no he didn't say but anyways but
meatballs just back there and i just
talked [ __ ] to him yeah but uh no toxic
work environment very very very toxic
work environment here i can't wait to
get rid of them but uh
you just move one office to the right
they're still right here
they're like well we still we still have
to do your audio
no uh but those were the [ __ ] days
yeah
like they don't really have anything
like that anymore
where they put out like but what's cool
is like you know you do have the funk
flex
he'll have people freestyle uh bootleg
kev will do it um who else um sway in
the morning yeah you know he'd have
people do the [ __ ] freestyles wait he
wrote a [ __ ] country song yes it's a
mate we don't have to watch it right now
but you should go if anyone's listening
check it out it's called so you've
always known about this dude yeah
yeah of course see you're you're a deep
diver huh yeah you call me deep dive
lacey do they d-d-l
yeah
yeah i like that too would you say
someone used to call you in high school
black bones black bones that's a great
band name i know black bones is dope
i like that but if i was if my band was
named black bones i would have to really
lean into [ __ ] being that hard and
i'm like i'm not trying to sing like
that but anyways no so you you deep dive
like that a deep dive
and i noticed it was actually jelly roll
posted that that blind fairy put out a
country song and this was like a couple
weeks ago shout out to jelly roll shout
out jelly and so i went and checked it
out did a deep dive on that it's amazing
dude it's really good that's what's so
crazy about this dude he's so
[ __ ] talented yeah insanely talented
like better than like most people you
would ever see yeah you know what i mean
i think i think the world should [ __ ]
know this dude and like everybody should
go back and watch his uh 106 of park
freestyle battles because he would just
annihilate
people you know everyone's like oh he's
right in he's right in
what
wow that was the thing people would say
that about him he's writing sounds like
big l
oh he kind of does
really in pocket yeah ooh he does
you know about big l
how do you know that casey
oh whatever and what shout out to big
y'all what do they mean he's writing he
he's they're like oh he he wrote that i
don't
how's he writing you know when you're
getting your ass beat uh-huh and you're
like man they had they had twenty feet
but they had like 20 [ __ ] people with
a man yo man he tried to jump you know
he had a he had a brass knuckle or
whatever i remember one time i beat up a
dude in uh junior high
and uh i remember
when we went back to school uh when i
went back to it was outside of school
you know what i mean because they
couldn't really do anything because it
was outside of school and
uh
we just had we just had got off the
school bus so we're like walking home so
that's i think there was like something
like oh we can't do anything you're out
of the premise yeah but i i beat up this
dude and he told uh and i [ __ ] him up
pretty bad
and uh i had anger problems
and he told the school
that i beat him up with my skateboard in
a chain
and a bat i was like i use all three
right [ __ ] weapons
which that would be crazy yeah i was
like
put it down it's like a [ __ ] you know
like uh what's that damn street the
streets of rage yeah streets of rage
where you had to pick up a [ __ ]
weapon it's like i just
find it what is the [ __ ] him up
choke him out with a chain obviously
they didn't believe that because he
would because i think if i beat him up
with my skateboard and [ __ ]
yeah dude you just had a black guy
[ __ ] chill right you know what i mean
you know but i was i was ruthless like
that but anyways yeah that's how i feel
like that's how people treat him in his
battles because yeah but i but like
that's that's a dude i [ __ ] deep dive
and go crazy on yeah
he has more [ __ ] battles
outside of that too yeah like like
outside of 106 of park he's been
battling okay you know it's like he's
just worked at it and i get it because
it's like the dude
people people want to rule it out the
fact that like
you know oh he he can't be that good
how's he that good there's no way he
could be that good and figure it's like
what else what
what else are you going to do
you could tell that he's just like in
his head like just great with word but
what but what you said yeah when you
talked about earlier when you were like
i spent i just listen listen to that
recording over and over and over and
over and over again yeah right so he
probably spends a lot of time
just doing that there's not i mean he's
obviously he's limited to to you know
because he's blind you know like to
stuff that he could do yeah but
if he like he found this one thing
that he just [ __ ] worked his ass off
to do yeah and he got good at it and
people want to rule that out when
someone's good at something yeah now
that always happens but yeah even when
you've heard this country song you
should check it out it's like you could
just tell that he's just a musician he's
good at any genre of music
i i got obsessed with this country song
where i had like a girl i was like
showing her i'm like we got to watch
blind fury's new country song she's like
okay like this is like a couple weeks
ago i'm like it's really good those are
the melodies here i'm just now like
appreciating country more
uh i haven't really
it's true john putting you on yeah tim
put me on yeah jim put me on like
there's a fair and also there's i didn't
realize how many country songs i
actually do like i i guess i just didn't
um
i don't know i just i don't know i just
i don't know like i guess i hear the pop
pop the super pop country and i go ugh
right i just get disgusted by it i just
got into it two years ago so you just
got it i just got into it too you need
to check out somebody that uh my fellow
uh
com comrade here is a comrade i don't
know you know the [ __ ] words i'm
trying
my friend here right uh casey yeah
charlie crockett charlie charlie
crockett is [ __ ]
amazing i gotta check it out oh my god
can't wait i when i saw when he showed
me him
i i don't know i think you were already
listening to it in the office and i go
and i walked in i go who is that
he was like it's charlie charlie
crockett that's my [ __ ] jam right
there
he's got an old-school style to him like
but like it's [ __ ]
are we allowed to play this [ __ ] we
can cut it out yeah
[Music]
you would probably like this guy named
tyler childers if you've never heard of
him he's crazy too
tyler childers yeah he's freaking
amazing but dude yeah so like because
you love music i do love me and you
appreciate like what goes into it and
like the intricacies and stuff so like
country just the songwriting is amazing
and the just structurally and like
melody wise like
that's what got me to grow to love it
yeah because i grew up you know right
next to kentucky so people listen to a
lot of country music there and me being
like a you know hip-hop fan and rock and
all that [ __ ] i was just on some
rebellious like i don't listen to
country i always said that my whole life
i was like anything but country but as i
got older i started to appreciate the
songwriting and just the i've said that
i've said that for years like yeah i'm
like
and which is like a dumb thing to say
like i'll listen to anything but country
it's like
because i remember
i remember uh
when i was in seventh grade
there's this teacher
that wanted us
gosh what was her [ __ ] name doesn't
matter anyways [ __ ] her yeah [ __ ] her
really though really really though
that [ __ ] lady
but also i was a [ __ ] right also i
was a [ __ ] but like we were just our
egos right they collapsed
our egos collided i [ __ ] hated her
how old how old were you i was in
seventh grade like 12 or 13. yeah yeah
anyways you're probably a little punk oh
i was she
was
jackass and that yeah she hated me
gosh i wish i remember her name anyways
she
she [ __ ] uh
she said hey i want everybody to bring
in a uh
a song
that um represents them represents them
like reflex you know like you know
pushes their
dope energy what makes you feel good
inside yeah you know
uh she goes i love music she wouldn't
even be she was an english teacher but
she was like i you know just want to put
that out there
you know once you guys express yourself
and she goes uh just can't be rap
and i was like
and i and i didn't listen i didn't
listen to much rap at the time i was
pretty heavy in to the rock so the rock
stuff
but i was like
why not i was like uh
i said that's dumb
i was yeah i was that guy you know just
right off the bat that's dumb right and
she said why is that dumb i was like
because what if there's a rap song that
this kid likes i was like how do you
want people to express themselves
if you're going to limit them to what
they can actually [ __ ] bring in
that's a good point you know this is me
in seventh grade
but also but it was music that i under
because it was like i know what
i knew how music made me feel right you
see what i'm saying i knew how music
made me feel yeah so it was just like
you know like hey you like you got to
keep that same energy with all mm-hmm
and she was a big beatles fan and i was
like what if i was like what if someone
was like oh you can't listen to the
[ __ ] beatles i said it like that too
i was like what if someone said that to
you and she sent me to detention and
[ __ ] but at the same time like it's
still like i thought it was just a dumb
assignment because i'm sure she thought
about that and also when i when i like
the thing i remember about that that
that scenario the most is when i when
she said that i actually saw
people get deflected mm-hmm you know is
that the word i'm looking for defensive
deflated okay uh okay
they could have been deflective too if
they were already like reflective and
like
it dimmed their shine you're gonna edit
that part out
leave that in
no bro it was deflective oh [ __ ] casey
can't spell
and that's his job is to spell stuff out
right here i know
i was worried you got time right
it says tim yeah
t-y-m-e
you cook with that
[Laughter]
you know that's like a bummer it's like
damn it but i but i like this dr dre
right one kid was going to bring in an
eminence it's like first of all the
build up to it is like you know the her
build up for it like i'll never forget
this day because it made me so [ __ ]
mad oh this is this where the anger
might no no okay okay that steps from
like three uh
it's just way deeper there's a position
way deeper than [ __ ] seventh grade
you think that [ __ ] started seventh
grade you were already choking kids out
with chase yeah
i mean if you want me to tell my friend
stories i can but uh
what was i saying no anyways but yeah
but like to see that and she built it up
yeah and then you know i went hard on
her for saying that and then i was like
how could i say that about country right
you know what i mean like i've been
listening to the things that like i
never thought i would ever [ __ ]
listen to
like
tame impala
amazing
and we had a moment we one of their
songs
i'll never forget listen dudes can have
moments together we had a moment
together you know i'm not gonna lie the
girls are always talking about oh we had
a moment yeah then we just became
friends yeah eat a dick dude's gonna
have that moment that's where we bonded
paula texas yeah we were in austin texas
yep and i don't even know what how it
came about well there's a song by
taympala called eventually and it we had
like both kind of been listening to it i
think on our own and you go bro there's
a song by tame impala and i go
eventually you're like yes and you press
play and we just sat there and vibe to
it on repeat repeat
for like for hours but but i like
that was my intro to uh
tame impala yeah amazing was uh was that
song eventually i was like damn this
song is really really good it's one guy
right it's one guy yeah but like i uh
but when he plays live he has a full
band okay but i think he pretty much
like does all he does all the
instruments and everything
to his songs yeah don't quote me on that
i guess we yeah let's look up that on
google because i don't want to like
discredit anybody that does like
help him out
or whatever but his name's kevin smith
right
or kevin parker kevin parker is his name
so tamiya paul is the psychedelic music
project of australian
multi-instrumentalist kevin parker as a
touring act at timon oh so oh it sounds
like he does
i'm pretty sure he's the lead vocalist
that does a lot of the production but he
has a team and he tours he tours with
people but there's this there's this
video on youtube where he's like i think
he i want to say he's creating the
maybe the slow rush album or maybe
currents one of those two albums yeah
but like he's like often like
in like somewhere in australia but it's
like you see like the beach like it's
all nice weather oh really it shows them
working on the project shows them
working on the project like
small small like area
or whatever but um he's someone
man amazing
[ __ ] insane incredible the production
work is great even like i watch the live
concerts on youtube because that's i'll
do that [ __ ] all day yeah but um like
even the light stuff like everything
that goes along with it you know and i
don't know if you do this too
do you do this where you go
where you'll uh
you'll hear a song
[Music]
and then go to youtube immediately see
how they do it live
like a song you like uh-huh i do that
[ __ ] all the time yeah yeah i like to
watch like all house created and yeah i
love to watch people's writing process
yes like how they like are they coming
up with it through melodies are they
writing together are they i love the
whole writing process of stuff yeah yeah
i mean i i'm noticing that [ __ ] like
because yeah i do have a band and our my
band has our first we have our first
show march 26th that's amazing yeah
yeah come through it's in orange county
oh yeah it'll be in orange county uh
i'll give more information do you guys
have a name yet your band name uh
i don't know if the whole band has
settled on it yet but i was like i like
this name but yeah that's cool i'll tell
you after you know cause casey won't
edit out anything i say yeah
[Laughter]
instead he just makes a compilation
and he'll title it
[Laughter]
that's funny but yeah like you know
cause
yeah i've been writing most of the songs
yeah i'll say it i'll give myself i'll
give myself the songwriter credit but
yeah i do write the songs you know dude
you have a great ear for it even when we
were writing together
and uh i was coming up with some of the
stuff because i do a lot of the writing
and
you were like hey why don't you put this
here and do this and i was like actually
yeah that's [ __ ] way better
you have a good knack for it i think
it's just but like also like
it's like when you think of
uh people that are really good at
something like like lebron james i'm not
saying lebron james but like lebron is
good because
he's pro like he's probably just bled
basketball yeah so you know what i mean
his whole [ __ ] life yeah that's why
he's [ __ ] lebron james michael jordan
yeah uh when you think of people that
are really really good and successful at
things
uh you're like that has been their
[ __ ]
thing they're usually absolutely i mean
they're just completely obsessed and
that's my thing with music i'd listen to
so much of it
that
yeah i could just catch things you know
there's this weird thing about me that
where
like i could hear a song that i've never
heard ever
and i know exactly how it's going to go
me too you can do that too i do that too
it's fun right yeah i like doing it
around certain people and they're like
have you heard this before yeah i've
like never heard this song i know never
heard it all the [ __ ] time you can
tell where they're going with it yeah i
was like oh i know exactly where because
right because it's like like
based off of where it's like
i don't know you could just tell you
could tell where though i can't even
explain how the progression goes the
melody yes what's funny is like when you
do it and sometimes you're wrong because
i've done it before and i'll be like
oh my gosh i thought it was something
else i know yeah all wrong song yeah
yeah it's like nine times out of ten
though yeah yeah get it right but no
that back to like that song creating
process like
you know what do you guys do how do you
guys how do you guys write so i
basically
i'll just be in my room and i write all
the riffs okay so you're going with it
with a guitar just you and i don't even
play guitar in the band right but uh you
start there
yeah i'll start with guitar
and then um
the thing i listen to the most in music
is drums
so i can so i can already map out the
drums in my head and how they're going
to go
based off of like
just playing the riff mm-hmm you know so
i'll play the riff and then
kind of like mumbling well like melodies
along while you're coming up with the
chords no see that's the part that's how
that i haven't done that okay and john
mayer said that's what he does right or
that's what you like need to do he said
if you're writing a song
like especially on guitar if you're
writing a song and you're not humming a
melody to it then it's going to make it
like kind of tricky when you when it
actually comes to that process
so i guess i need to like
you know start at least humming
something yeah to it but i find myself
like
you know i think everyone has their own
writing process you know yeah but i
thought that was like a unique thing and
i need to try that way
uh so shout out to john mayer for giving
me that info that's cool uh well that's
what a lot of people do he didn't he
didn't necessarily he texted it to you
directly he didn't yeah it was a youtube
video yeah
well i like to think he was like
chappelle would you write
when you write a song
hey spells me john mayer
when you write a song like you know make
sure you're yeah doing the melodies but
yeah then so then i'll yeah so i'll get
the guitars do that i'll do guitar
and then um
i'll go to joel my drummer
mostly sorry mostly sorry
shout out to joel super talented yep
then i'll go to him and then he'll be
like where do you hear the drums at and
i go i hear him here here hearing this
yeah and what joel does
is goes above and beyond what i'm
actually i go what i go my shitty drum
thought
like because he just [ __ ] he's a
really good [ __ ] drummer he is go to
mostly uh on instagram
type in mostly sorry
and he's super talented comedian too oh
dude he's hilarious amazing oh yeah you
came when you
saw him open for me yeah scroll down a
little bit
he's got a he's got this video where
he's drumming to
uh
[ __ ] uh bone thugs in harmony
so fire scroll
no no not right there that that was a
pennywise drum he was doing
keep scrolling you'll see a green screen
just keep go scroll until you see a
green screen
on the right try that one is it that one
no it's not that one scroll again
right there
how hard is that
that's sick how dope is he that's really
dope
he i mean he like he i don't know he's
got a dope style to him
go to that other one
the one that's like the great that right
there
[Music]
so i would like to say i have the dope i
have one of the dopest drummers
to be able to play in uh a band with but
yeah
he's amazing i remember he came to that
valley video shoot and he heard the song
10 seconds he's like yeah i got it and
he's just already ripping right he's so
good yeah he's he's so good but that's
cool he brings your you have the ideas
and he brings them to life yep and then
and then uh
you know then our other guitarist uh
chris
so me and another second guitar uh chase
will
he and i will usually come up like these
riffs together i'll just throw it at him
and he'll he'll jam it too and he
elevates it to like another level yeah
he's really good and then chris
uh
who's the lead guitar he'll come up with
like he'll just hear it and
start doing these [ __ ]
leads to it to where i'm like yes and
then our bass player uh ryan who's
literally and what's funny about it
we're all comedians
uh but like ryan will come through and
have these dope grooves to follow along
with joel
you know the drumming so it's it's dope
to see it like actually come to life
like it's like rift that i came up with
with and all that and then then i'll
just get in with the lyrics which is
[ __ ] hard yeah
lyrics are hard
hard yeah
yeah but you do it i do it i do the
melodies first and i do the lyrics
usually
okay yeah it's because it's like
something that helps how [ __ ] you know
you want what do you want to [ __ ]
talk about well
here's the thing this is probably what
john mayer was trying to tell you
[Laughter]
john hey i dm'd you bro get back to me i
you know i dm'd you to come on the show
anyway
i did i really i shot my shot
for real yeah that was so sick i shot my
shower jam hey if you listen to this
episode tag john
john mayer get him on the show
yeah but like i think he was as you're
saying what he was trying to probably
trying to say is like
the melody is like
what you're trying to say without even
saying it so far so it's like it no it's
kind of hard to explain but it's
basically your intuition it's like when
you're humming humming a melody to the
to the to the music that's like what
you're trying to say that's what's
resonating and what you're feeling right
so then you just put lyrics to like what
you're already trying to say
so like
okay and like sometimes it'll help me to
have someone with me because like i work
with read a lot who you met bass god and
he's my producer so sometimes i'll be
listening to a track on repeat and i'm
humming these melodies to it no no no no
no and
and he'll be like oh it hurt it sounded
like you said this and then we'll start
writing from there kind of really yeah
it kind of depends though like sometimes
i'll write two tracks bro how the [ __ ]
you just expect me to understand that
well
he just broke it down like well that's a
scientific [ __ ] yeah pythagorean
theorem
casey shut up
while i'm explaining that can you edit
like that scientific equation
behind chapelle where he's like what did
you carry the two
because literally as you're explaining
it i'm like it's it's a compliment the
reason it's so hard to explain is
because it's like trying to explain a
feeling
because you already know the filling you
know yeah
that's why it's hard to put in words
because it's like it's just whatever you
feel like yeah well because when i think
about like
songs that like
have amazing lyrics an amazing message
you're like
like i didn't realize it because i liked
that song eventually yeah because of
what it was doing
and then you were like yo read those
lyrics yeah and then i read the lyrics
and i was like
well that's when it yeah it [ __ ] me up
both merge that's when it's an amazing
song yeah when the melody and the
feeling can match the lyrics and how
powerful they are i think that's when
you have like a great song
man
i would love to see you like
collab with something like that yeah
with like uh
uh
tame impala oh that'd be sick yeah do
you have any like dream collaborations
you [ __ ]
i mean
i mean i guess that'd be amazing it
really comes in waves you know because i
love to make all type all different
types of genres
so like even on my laptop i'll have a
folder full of like 20 different vibes
that like one could be tame impala type
one could be
a way of like just uh beats you've made
yeah just like just songs i've started
like i'll just have a big library of
melodies i've started
really and then i might bring them back
later and put them on something else so
you'll be like
for a melody like you're kind of just
like
yeah i'll just hum really yeah but
usually i can kind of already know what
words are there
i can kind of already meet in the middle
like i was saying like i can
freestyle the the words to the melody
yeah and and i i guess with me because
the way my brain thinks yeah i'm like
there's so many ways you can go with
this
so it's like how do i lock into one
thing well that's the beauty of it is
like and i don't want it to sound like
the same things someone's heard right
you know that like i try to like write
yeah that way and that it's tough like
and also i listen to so much [ __ ]
music so like there's times where i'm
like oh that sounds i'm like damn it
that sounds just like [ __ ] these guys
i go why the [ __ ] did i do that but but
then
it it makes me fight to switch it up
like it gives me this like fire to be
like well okay well how about you take
this stick and make it
make it completely [ __ ] different and
it's like oh there it is i think that's
the beauty of it too because just
because you come up with the first thing
doesn't mean that's how it's going to
end up so just like you could change it
a thousand times along the way
even that valley song that it came out
as a rock like hard drums yeah that
started as like a hip-hop like trap song
you know so we started there with that
original melody
i don't remember how we started it but
eventually we said something that was
like when you left me
and like just that melody alone we
switched the drums and we changed it
like 10 times along the way until it
ends oh so that so that is like a common
thing yeah i think that's the beauty of
it is to be open-minded and allow
feedback and stuff and and change it
until it's different and fresh yeah
hmm
yeah
but that's the beauty of it that's why
it's cool you got a band cause you guys
could bounce ideas off each other and
make it come to life yeah yeah cool way
it's it's so funny because like
you know when i was first
like when we first started jamming i had
realized something like i would come in
with a riff but it would just be the
riff right like it's just like and then
i'm like oh that's all i have right
you know and then then we would have to
do this like puzzle piece
thing
to where
like it just didn't
i found it being less productive for us
you know trying to like puzzle piece it
out and i was like yo finish it like
don't don't like come with them with
like something that you have
something fully mapped out because then
it was then when i started doing that
like we found if it's been easier for us
to like actually collab and like yeah do
something and then when i just come with
like i got an internet right and they're
like yeah yeah
record it you know anyway yeah so so
like now i've like come up with full
pieces
of the
of the songs then it allows everyone to
go and do their part yeah oh you got
this that that inspired me to do this
yeah now guitar now drums now yeah yeah
i'll and i'll play you a little bit oh
yeah
yeah i can't wait there's no vocals to
it yet yeah yeah i'll play you a little
bit for sure uh i'm kind of nervous for
the live show
you know because you're gonna crush it's
different standup's different yeah you
know but you you just started doing live
shows what did in 2021 yeah last year
yeah yeah
dude the best feeling i've ever felt in
my [ __ ] life right like yeah the best
dude it's fun watching you thanks bro
yeah you like getting like you you
you're
um you're not one that just like
like you want to have fun with your
music yeah that's how that's what i
think of when i see you perform it's
like oh this guy wants to have fun with
his music you know some people just like
like oh gosh
like if you look at some people nowadays
like you know especially rappers
like bands it's a little different you
know you could you could
the the instruments are so loud
you know to where it's like you know it
just gets out there but
like if you're a rapper sometimes it's
just it's literally just you yeah it's
almost like stand up right you're the
only one on the stage
you know what i mean so it's like you
have to like
give so much life to a [ __ ]
performance
you know what i mean and and like you
actually care to like
like it looks like you like love your
songs that's cool you know what i mean
like yeah you don't go out like like i
watch i watch so many [ __ ]
like i said
live performances yeah and there's some
writers that'll go up there and they
know they have a hit song
and the songs that hit
and then they do it live and it's like
this song is a hit you should just like
it because it's a hit it's basically
like press play and let it let it do the
work it's like no that's [ __ ]
no i want to see you [ __ ] go off to a
song yeah that you made that so many
people [ __ ] love
like that's what i [ __ ] like yeah
yeah for sure is that how you feel is
that how you feel about you on stage or
like yeah what like what was your
thought going into it like you're like
what were like the i guess the ground
rules you had set for yourself to be
like yeah well so the first time i
performed was with brendan and with you
guys in texas
and
that i just didn't even know like i
didn't even i didn't tell anyone i've
never performed live before i didn't
want to make it a big deal brennan's
like you want to do some songs and i'm
like yep i just packed my bags and went
yeah yeah so that one i was just like i
don't [ __ ] know hopefully i can know
this but
i think i did pretty good so i was like
and then afterward i told brendan and
all you guys i was like that was my
first time ever performing live he's
like jesus christ why don't you say
something you're a liability bro yeah
but it went well but i think now that
i've been starting to do it a little
more it's like the biggest release for
me it's the it's the time i can have fun
with the song it's like all this was
leading up to being able to perform it
and
having fun you know because sometimes in
the studio and i'm really like i take it
very serious about how the sound comes
out and everything okay so it's a lot of
work you know it's like this isn't right
we got to change this so that's not
particularly fun all the time like
making sure it sounds amazing so by the
time i get to perform it that's when i
get to have fun with it yeah and i like
that i like that about you man thank you
yeah when when you
because i saw you perform in austin but
my second time seeing you perform again
was in arizona arizona in phoenix which
you came and thank you for coming out
though yeah yeah crazy of course no that
was crazy that was nice i know well you
started doing a chevelle song and i
walked out all i did was turn it all i
did was just
that was in your spot bro they love you
out there i know it is pretty cool but
yeah but like that was that was so that
was so obviously i remember the first
performance right and then to see where
you're at
on the next one like you already had the
energy like it was already in you in
that first performance right now i was a
little out of breath now yeah but now
you have this clarity uh-huh and it
seems like you have this clarity shout
out to john mayer that's a song by john
mayer clarity uh it's a good song uh
i've covered it before uh it's actually
really hard to play but uh
link in the description yeah link in the
description uh i'm added to the playlist
after that but yeah it was so it was
cool to see like it's like oh like
dude yeah you because it's like you
probably i see the progress in the music
and then to see the progress and the
live performance too it's you know it's
dope to see someone actually like fully
[ __ ] care
about what they're doing yeah
you know yeah
yeah man we and and shout out to chin we
spent some time rehearsing and like
getting it right yeah yes yes
and that helps a lot because
you know i think i have some music out
but not a huge catalogue so i think that
helped keep it interesting when we
performed i do my songs there's some rap
songs chin we switch off chin comes out
and sings i come back out there's like
some more rock songs it's like a just a
whole experience
so it's not just like me coming out
pressing play on a rap song and being
like now vibe to it it's more of like
kind of like a rock show where it's like
i want to turn up with the crowd i want
to see people do you have you have any
more live shows coming up or you just
kind of just well i've been working on
these projects here but i want to do
some live soon we wanted to do la and
like west coast a little more um so i
think hopefully me and shane can get
some rolling yeah yeah
yeah i think yeah and uh you had a great
turnout in phoenix and i think if you
went back you would have a even bigger
turnout too that'd be you know what i
mean yeah that like you know that's a
market you know that i think you guys
were strong only because i was there
right right yeah and like you could kind
of tell it's like oh if they came back
here like they would they would get a
[ __ ] another
you know
set of [ __ ]
people to [ __ ] come out yeah i'm
looking forward to performing more just
working on some albums right now put
some music out and then hopefully get
back out there it was cool to see you
perform in a place that i was i've been
going to since i was a kid dude that
venue was sick yeah the rebel shout out
to the rebels
it used to be called the mason jar okay
back in the day and fun fact
nirvana performed there that's sick
yeah but i think it was they performed
there
before dave grohl
and i want to say it was 1990.
was it
89 or 90.
type in go to youtube
type in nirvana mason jar
phoenix yeah
oh who am i
let's go who am i when was it 99.99
1990. wow what is my name
yeah deep dive lazy i remember
i just realized the goofiest [ __ ] yeah
dude we were in we were in seattle yeah
i was uh with brendan yeah
on the road and we went to that museum
of
pop culture
and we were in there
and they have like a grunge exhibit
they have a pearl jam exhibit they have
all this stuff all these exhibits is
pretty [ __ ] dope yeah but there was a
shirt
that was donated
from eddie vedder from pearl jam
and i saw that shirt i was like damn
uh i was standing next to jay i was like
damn i know exactly where that
where what what concert he wore that
shirt at in what year and i was like it
was pink pop 1992
in uh germany or something like that
and uh he was like really i was like
yeah watch and i pulled up the exact
concert where he wore that shirt at and
they were like what the [ __ ] that's the
kind of that's the kind of weird [ __ ]
that you remember yeah yeah but you like
that too yeah i i just things i'm
interested in
yeah you know yeah exactly like
it's like but like to them that's like
crazy but it's like to them that's like
them knowing some football [ __ ] yeah i
don't know anything about [ __ ] yeah
yeah i mean either
two shits i know my least favorite thing
to cheer when i cheerlead
was football was your favorite
basketball oh yeah that's why i was the
best games actually volleyball oh yeah
yeah
yeah i can recall
[Music]
saw just songs melodies like
any genre like when i was little i'd be
at the barber shop i remember and i'd be
at in my barber's chair and he was
playing songs on the radio right it was
probably like late 90s like early 2000s
and he was playing music and every song
he would play i would start singing
along to it and know all the lyrics and
he'd go man you know we have a rule in
here if you sing the song we got to
change the station and i'm like oh he
changed the station i knew that song too
then he too
and i remember like they were laughing
about it so were you just like into like
the radio i'm just into yeah just music
like were you like locked into the radio
as a kid yeah and i think by then the
internet was starting to come out my
brother introduced me to napster and
lime
limewire limewire yeah viruses all on
the computer come on now i'll crash at
my computer
yeah but uh yeah i've just been obsessed
with music since i was little and
yeah that's why i geek out about just
just can recall all that [ __ ] yeah
all right so this is the point of the
show where i do these rapid questions oh
let's do it all right favorite band all
right are we talking uh like full like
full band or like yeah i'll break it
down for you because you listen to so
much so i'll go i'll go favorite rapper
and favorite band so favorite band i
mean my favorite person that has a band
my favorite artist is bon iver that's my
all-time favorite is a bonavir bon iver
it's bony bear funny
bunny bear
that's how they say it
i'm not going to say it like
yeah
like i know one of his albums one who's
got like a cartoon dude on it yeah i
don't know what that apple's called i
don't know but he's my favorite like
singer bonavear
really yeah
interesting that's my favorite i would
have never thought that yeah he's my
favorite uh like singer artist and he
plays with a band
but
yeah that's just my favorite like i have
to say him okay yeah uh favorite rapper
favorite rapper
that's a hard one
i mean eminem's up there from like when
i was younger yeah i think he's the goat
but also like what resonated more with
me was lil wayne growing up
wheezy fair yeah fair one that's the
time period i was in like
of course like i think puck and and big
l and
biggie like i respect their lyricism and
i think they're amazing but like i was
growing what hit you well i was 12 when
like wayne was dropping those mixtapes
that's what i was listening to over and
over again my friend would burn a cd and
i'd be like no one has this yet like
this is new wayne so this is a good one
yeah uh favorite concert we've gone to
favorite concert this is a random one
okay it's a tie between two can i do two
yeah cause kid cudi did a show in ohio
one time called the glow-in-the-dark
tour
and kanye was there what was that right
on the
was that his first album or the i think
it was a second
the man on the moon yeah i think maybe
it was the a little after the first he
was playing a lot of the first yeah but
that just hit so different i've been
because i was he's from there and i was
like 18 and i was into smoking weed and
i was into music yeah so that show like
hit me just crazy bruh that song
soundtrack to my life yeah that he
played that there and i was like this
[ __ ]
makes my [ __ ]
i don't know it just captures my yeah
soul it's like a cellular level god damn
yeah you just feel it yeah god damn it's
a great show it was amazing i was also
really stoned uh-huh but it was great to
experience it like that the lighting
everything was sick
so that that was the tie between that
one and this one's a little more
underground there's this band called wet
w-e-t
it's a female singer
it's got make sure you caught the way he
spelled it yeah w-e-t well like that's
how i spell it with the acronym
[Laughter]
spells it with like three t's
well uh they did a show and it's
basically this female singer with a
super angelic voice they did a show in
la and it was amazing it was like a
similar vibe where it just like catches
you and yeah kind of sounds like tame
impala a little bit okay i gotta check
them out what yeah okay i gotta take it
it might throw you off a little bit it's
like it's like just a singer
by the game or carter two by wayne oh
yeah
really yep
highly respect those go
dude and once again the documentary the
documentary by the game
dude i [ __ ] love that album yeah
black wall street yes yeah dude yeah
that and of course i'm not saying those
are the greatest albums of all time to
me like i think there's maybe better
words people when you do this [ __ ] where
it's like why do you think that's
integrated first of all it has nothing
to do with you let's go it has to do
with him yeah it's his [ __ ] favorite
shout out to that
you people drive me [ __ ] crazy when
you do [ __ ] like that whereas why do you
think that's the best one that's not the
best one i think this one yeah you think
yeah and i i accept that you think
[ __ ]
we got the teacher to blame for this
sorry i know right i'm getting all that
that'd be funny if you asked me my
favorite and you're like no rap though
you're like what's up now i hold the
power that's [ __ ] favorite album not
raptor no rap
not in here
it's out of here but yeah because you
know what because when i was that age my
older brother who i love and respect and
think he's so cool you know i'm 12 and
he's 16 or some [ __ ] so like he's the
goat like he's whatever he says is cool
it's cool he was putting me on the game
he was putting me on the way his [ __ ]
the game is amazing we were watching the
game documentaries like he posted
something
uh real quick before we do this he's
about to put out a project yeah he's
about to put out go to go to it's los
angeles confidential this is uh
no no his
instagram
los angeles count confidential
yeah yep the top one
so
they uh go to the right where that list
is yeah and so he posted it and he
didn't make
i think is [ __ ] insane me too i saw
this like what
yeah chappelle lacy liked it but uh
crazy to me yeah i think the game is
[ __ ]
the game is [ __ ] fire yeah
like you can't like
ah
my favorite track off that documentary
is uh higher
it's not that i can't stop is that i
won't stop i'll make it hot i'll do it
right crazy crazy yeah bro i was a huge
fan me and my like my brother put me on
i had his merch i had like a black wall
i like went on their website that was
like not a lot of people got their stuff
and i found like black wall street teas
and like all this [ __ ] i loved i loved
the game i [ __ ] with the game heavy
yeah so that album meant the most to me
along with the carter two i think is one
of the best rapping albums
and that's what i got uh money on my
mind yeah money hustler music [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah not not [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't mean
that that's what wayne said respect
women i respect women oh yeah and then
and when i say [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm talking
about mean people
and that could be guy or a girl yep
yep
uh so
[Laughter]
so now we do this uh
uh i like to do
cool bro yeah i like to do a soundtrack
you see what i'm saying yeah i love
doing this this is your
vibe yeah chappelle's work
but uh so yeah i like to do a playlist
with every guest at the end of each
episode okay uh we do like 10 to 12
songs we just go back and forth yeah and
so basically it's a
soundtrack and a vibe to the episode
that i like to deliver to fans so like
when they listen to this playlist they
think can i put random stuff on there
like people's never heard yeah okay cool
i'll go first i'll start with uh
i'll do eventually tame impala wow great
number one track yeah we'll start off
with that great number one track i've
been wanting i've been trying to find a
way to put that onto a playlist but like
since we talked about it today i was
like [ __ ] yeah yeah
i'm gonna go with uh
there's actually
you know my favorite thing about doing
this casey is i can always tell when a
guest is really in it because they they
pull out their phone
yeah i'm gonna go with there's a song
called control alt delete and the artist
is corbin c-o-r-b-i-n
he used to go by spooky black when he
was younger yeah i don't know if you
ever heard of him
but anyway that song
oh my god
okay we got it we got it you know you
got it you did it right you did it right
[Laughter]
all right i'll go
uh
i'll do the game higher wow
yup
all right i'm going to switch it up a
little bit um there's a song by matt
mason switch up it's called nelson wood
lane
and i also just did a remix to it that
i'm gonna drop in like a week or so so
if no one's ever heard that song check
it out okay it's amazing it's a little
more folky but uh it's dope
we'll do uh oh then since we're going
that route
why don't we do blind fury's song
country song country song is it called
it's called i you don't know the half
it's on spotify and stuff i think it's
on everything it's on everything so
we'll do blind fury you don't know the
half oh this playlist is gonna be fine
dude i know
i'm actually i'm excited all right well
since you got me on the show i'm gonna
put one of my own songs on there that
just came out low brows internet browser
put it on there so after you listen to
that blind fury song let this take you
on some rap stuff
okay yeah and then uh
oh i got one for you on this next one
you do yeah i'm trying to think of where
to take it that's what i love about it
is like where to take it it's a journey
right now yeah
um
the internet oh okay uh
we'll do one more folky one i'll do i'll
do charlie crockett five more miles yeah
you spelled his name wrong no
yep oh yeah
it's l-e-y
charlie crockett i know you're based out
of austin texas but when when but when
you're in los angeles bro you you're
coming on the show
anyways
shout out to charlie crockett love that
dude
okay so now how many songs total
keep going go get go oh we just keep
going yeah i was thinking where to take
it with that now so charlie crockett all
right now we're going to take it to uh
one of my friends my boy riley
oh love riley which if you guys haven't
heard him before dude y'all got it so
it's riley r-i-l-e-y
yeah like all caps sorry that's just how
you look it up i don't know yeah um
and this song is called call it what you
want
if you guys haven't heard of him before
i know chappelle knows his music and
stuff he's right right check out riley
he's super out riley riley's [ __ ]
amazing yeah so that's cool he's got
some newer stuff out as well
uh the project that made me fall in love
with him was uh the project los angeles
l-o-s-s angelus um
dude i wanna do
oh yeah
let's do john mayer
yeah what john mayer's song do i want to
do because i have something yeah we'll
do clarity i like claire rarity that's a
good one
um
okay okay i'm gonna put kit cuddy
soundtrack to my life on there right
after clarity oh
oh my god this [ __ ] playlist this is
going to be a roller coaster yeah that's
not how you spell kid cuddy kid cootie
yeah cootie
see you die
bro you remind me of my boyfriend he
can't spell really and like he uses talk
to text and it still comes out wrong
[Laughter]
how right
how many songs we got i don't want to be
a dick but it is c-u-d-i though
oh did i i didn't say that did i say
that i thought i think yeah yeah yeah
okay oh yeah yeah um
what you say about um
my boy can't spell freddie
he uses talk to text and it still comes
out wrong yeah
how many how many songs have we got
tim
should we throw a bonus on there
that's a good that's a good playlist
gosh what's that mean
what's that one kid's net because i was
thinking charlie crockett austin and
there's this other cat i think he's out
of dallas too shaky graves tyler
childers no no no no uh [ __ ] why am i
blanking on his name
gosh someone's gonna beat me up for this
one let's give someone a shout out
[ __ ]
gosh he's got a dope npr
i don't know oh lee sorry there we go
whoo you got him uh leon bridges oh
wow you're gonna end it with that
maybe uh uh maybe coming home oh
coming home and that's a good way to end
it yeah that's a good outro song yep
wow look at that
okay i'm gonna say this that's a that's
a dope playlist where can we find this
playlist so at the end of uh so at the
end of every episode so uh
when when people go to the youtube
channel or to youtube to watch it the
it's in the the link is in the bio dope
yep i'm going to be listening to it
because i know right yeah and i want to
hear more of that charlie crockett dude
because that what you showed me was sick
yeah yeah he's he's [ __ ] shout out to
casey for that one and shout out to
meatball for always being as great as he
is to me yeah
you thought i was gonna talk
anyways uh thank you for coming in
little brows of course and i can't wait
to can't wait to work with you again too
me too you know let's get some more
music out there we'll [ __ ] do it
let's get it all right yeah
you